en ce qui concerne l'essence, nous avons effectué
un très grand nombre de tests
et d'examens afin que nous puissions sentir qu'il
était organique, nous ne voulions pas qu'il s'agisse
des effets en soi, nous avons donc examiné
vous savez divers flous et traînées et  nous nous sommes
retrouvés avec quelque chose qui, je pense, est
assez simple et mais aussi assez
sophistiqué et plutôt élégant comme
solution pour pietro comme ce
sentier de rue bleu quand je cours pour nous, vous verrez que
vous savez que la lumière ne peut pas est-ce '  J'aurai
ce genre de coup de foudre
, vous voyez des photos de
Scarlet Witch et elle est toujours comme
nous avons donc ces images et celles-ci comme vous le
savez, des boules rouges autour de ses mains pour une
sorte d'énergie de feu et Jos
voulait vraiment que je le fasse  travailler avec la danseuse, cela
a beaucoup changé la conversation sur la façon dont
Scarlet Witch se déplacerait en quelque sorte en
créant un vocabulaire, nous avons pris son pouvoir
et avons dit d'accord si vous aviez la télékinésie, elle
pourrait déplacer des choses, elle pourrait avoir un
peu d'énergie pour se protéger
ou pousser et  s  il peut entrer dans votre
tête et et et le modifier pour que toutes
vos pires peurs soient mises en
évidence.
la cendre hadu
elle est morte